sur le moment bien sûr le moment qu'est
ce que je voyais pendant la guerre
pendant là qu'est ce que je voyais que
je voyais au début un isolement
considérable dans une dans un océan de 2
le soumission un abattement moral
considérable
qu'est ce qu'on voyait envoyé ce qui
levait la tête c'étaient des terroristes
terroristes
[Musique]
moi mon boulot j'étais d'avoir les yeux
ouverts passé derrière était nécessaire
parce que c'était un type qui attire et
qui attiré les foules non verts qui a
tiré qu'à qui passaient quelque part ça
se voyait
il ya pas tellement vide le pouvoir
c'est d'ailleurs vrai il n'a pas envie
de revoir tous et tous les témoins
il était en avance de 60 ans le conte
sur ce qui se passe maintenant moi moi
il me semble et sympathique statut
d'intérimaire tous sièges c'est vraiment
un chef mais il est un peu simplet oui
c'est que il avait des idées on essaie
simplement et ben oui mais c'est idée de
transformer le mans de préparer le mans
demain alors il était aidé par ce qu'on
appelait les commuters d'où provient
cette crise
elle provient de ce que l'humanité n'a
pas pris conscience de la signification
de sa conquête
elle n'a pas compris qu'un
bouleversement économique est
nécessairement lié un bouleversement des
rapports moraux intellectuels politiques
c'est pourquoi la première révolution la
révolution nécessaire c'est la
réadaptation de nos consciences
il nous faut savoir à quel destin cette
puissance mécanique nous permet
d'aspirer il y va de notre liberté et de
notre vie que notre volonté domine ce
mouvement économique aveugle qui
aujourd'hui nous entraîne
c'est moi en janvier 44 aujourd'hui
janvier 44
ça c'est le camp le camp cyrus y avait
six russes brunel mois guan there may
était loin de futur et sur cette photo
alors ça c'est tellement gros la ja
brunel c'est pas son nom société bic aux
ahmadis
charlie joe nick et rodin président - ar
mor aramis annette alpaga basané brest
bib brut ion carrier brunel chevassu
chiron car à curtis cyrus drakkar dati
durandal dupré freine jorioz guy gas
mimo rend si simone talons c'est vranes
pelvoux tony yann tous du service
périclès fondée par sarrazac soulage
alias robert pour former les cadres
nécessaires à l'afflux de réfractaires
au st lô dans les maquis
toby clark quenelle charlie réfractaires
puis maquisards du haut jura
emmenés par les cadres de périclès
soixante dix huit filles pour me suis
lâchée par louis denis d'affi celui-là
le marcel ferraro il est encore en vie
puis chez paou les autres et fils à ça à
la première page il ya la photo de mes
copains m'ont pranger enfin tous les
copains du quartier
roger longchamp
roger bride nouyrigat dr cavalli gens en
cas mon frangin au milieu mbola ho en
ôtant aux au mieux des trop et puis on
va appliquer sur l'ambiance
sochaux vainqueur et et en face les
class 40 41 42 avaient reçu leur noble
alors de partir en allemagne de signer
un contrat 18 mois narain pour le reste
et au moi je vais vraiment pas l'idée de
porter en allemagne surtout je me suis
je teins d'erreurs qui ne suis pas fait
recette il n'est pas passé de visite
médicale
comme ça j'ai gagné d'avoir eu des
recherches d'un côté c'est très bien
mais un jour qu'en gt gt chez nous chez
mes parents à mes parents me disent
alors qu'est ce que tu fais tu vas
partir du nombre important que c'est
comme les copains répandent mathier les
motivations étaient pour les mêmes pour
tous 1 n'était pas
veut dire carrément de droite 1 d'abord
contre le gouvernement de kaboul
gouvernement actuel mon père mon père
ayant fait la mère de 14 n'était pas
pour les hommes en bleu il ya eu déjà
une manifestation des bonnes femmes des
mères les maires de ceux qui avaient
reçu leur carte dans la vie du chrétien
je l'avais reçu leur carte bleue samedi
mais elles sont à l'école et jusque
devant la sous préfecture
et puis le labour c'est là qu'on m'a
appris qu'il y avait là la ministre
faisait sa première réunion à aubin
douche les bons fameuse ont sorti les
parapluies ça y allait quand ils sont
sortis en prime de ses volets j'ai vu le
commissaire de police
quand vint marron qui jonglait sur 100 m
quelque chose de bien
les flics ils pouvaient rien faire ce
qu'ils avaient fait venir leurs troupes
et puis dans la nuit ils ont fait venir
des dg maire de meaux dernière deux
bouts de bourthes qui était devant la
mairie puis ça manifester la doit sans
cogner sur les icônes y ait sur les
pieds avec leur crosse de fusil mais sa
gouverne une chochotte
et puis là c'est là que tout se
déciderait en somme les modos grand
penser ce qu'ils voulaient se sauver il
fallait aller à cergy et ses clacs a
commencé mais ça cognait les bonnes
femmes avec les parapluies
or francis a dû l'imposer liste des
lieux on est allé au chalet déjà drake
le chemin d adrien théaux ware est
arrivé par là par le bois bas et puis en
étant très part au chan et par derrière
il y avait déjà quelqu'un qui nous
attendait et on savait pas qui c'était
les réfractaires des adrets ont été
prises en charge par la fraternelle
réseau résistants issu du mouvement
socialiste coopératif de saint claude
très vite la grande affluence dans les
chalets incite la fraternelle à chercher
d'urgence un encadrement militaire
contacté le mouvement combat les met en
rapport avec robert sarrazac soulage qui
décide en août 43 de transférer les
écoles de cadres des alpes dans le jura
jean macé pour la mémoire
allez on s'envoie il est vrai une
réduction ou alors quand on est depuis
le fresnoy qu'on allait jusque là haut
tu auras mis en eau chercher des
chevrets chez les petits fromages carré
on allait chercher du chevret repensée
derrière pas la traverse est remonté à
bord vers chez le joindre pour rejoindre
devant chez le gars ont montré tout le
monde roule toujours à la lisière des
bois bourse a refilé quand on entend un
contre personne mais quand on a été
prévenu par le seul amour à tous les
gendarmes arriver qu'ils ont nettoyé
lacombe
enfin ils ont nettoyé ils en ont pris là
bas en haut
il en en pris 1 chez le père qui était
malade qui était couché chez un fermier
et puissant descendu mais nous ça nous a
fait chaud ça nous a chassés de notre
pays de notre chalet
un matin qu'est ce qu'on voit sur le
bord de la route
vous voyez la route des cheveux qui
arrivait à papier et puis un type en
officier à cheval est allé voir d'abord
on se planquer dans le bourg on les a
regardés passer ils ont passé à
cinquante mètres de nous sans vouloir un
moment on avait rien là pour se battre
en mars 44 14 réfractaires sont
massacrés à la ferme de gare de chemin
par l'armée allemande et la milice
c'était c'était un peu le chaos un
moment avec avec les dimensions guerre
civile très nette qui avait les il y
avait une ministre à sion
et c'était collabos les chefs tu là
c'était la police l'armée la milice
souza roberta fait au début quand ils
savent pas quoi faire de moi encore il
m'a dit dis donc tu vas aller voir deux
ou trois officiers qui sont les
camarades à moi les camarades d'école ou
saint maixent au jeu par contre je sais
pas où mais des gt avec eux dans l'armée
et jolie bien aller voir essaye d va
parrainer un petit mot et
on essaye de les recruter je me souviens
le 3 mai n'avait probablement deux ou
trois cinq ou six je suis allé voir je
me souviens de 3 sur ces 3 aucun n'est
venu et a au moins mal très mal reçue le
2 autres la bible abla oui on va voir
voir venir
misérable pétainiste misérable officiers
misérable bourgeois qui avait renoncé au
nom de la discipline de l'ordre du
réalisme à la lutte contre l'oppresseur
et qui avait trahi la vocation de la
france
nous vous mais prison comme l'histoire
vaut méprisera vous avez servi l'ennemi
et son astucieuse propagande qui n'a pas
eu d'autre but que de nous anesthésier
pour paralyser notre volonté de lutte
gaubens et s'essaye de vichy marion
henriot et les journalistes stipendiés
n'ont pas eu de soucis plus constant que
de chloroformé la france pour lui faire
oublier que la guerre continuait que son
sort si jouer
kelly avait sa place qu'elle restait en
guerre nous sommes battus nous sommes
battus répète à vichy il faut payer de
gaulle était condamné à mort et l'on
croyait ainsi changé en au cadavre la
volonté de guerre d'un pays
un soir ils s'empressaient le cavaliere
monde il faut que ce soit fini demain
table alors je tapais encore 11 heures
d'histoire de 10 ans frappe à la porte
un boubou
olala mon coeur je dis mais qu'est ce
que c'est et gilbert m'avait dit tu vois
tu tapes à la machine tout ce qu'on te
donne mais par dessous tu diras que tu
travailles pour un théâtre que tu tapes
des scènes de théâtre annuler le tir au
dessus et tu la mets dessus comme ça
s'il vient de voir
alors vite je suivais ouvrir mon coeur
qui saute et j'étais pas courageuse mais
vous savez ce que c'est et c'était la
défense passive
ils me disent alors madame qu'est ce que
vous faites de ces heurts c'était 11
heures du soir
je leur expliquais vous savez il faut
que ça soit prêt pour demain la défense
passive bien et de lumière qui passe on
le voit du dehors vous allez par honte
il me dit
pouf contents ils sont partis comme ça
ma mère qui avait accepté difficilement
de de me voir entrer en résistance
d'abord dit oui puis un président bien
et c'était allemagne et coûteux
j'accepte mais à condition que tu le ne
quitte pas lyon qui dure entre tous les
soirs la maison j'ai laissé mon travail
je suis entré dans la clandestinité aux
cerises périclès alors j'ai commencé
il avait été question que j'aille
travailler je crois autant que j'ai pu
savoir avec robert m'avait dit que
c'était le grand chef robert bon ben
voila quoi on s'appelait rêver d'un
premier sur m'a dit de choisir un
pseudonyme
et puis et puis où j'en étais on m'avait
emmené à bron c'est aux alentours de
lyon dans une maison isolée
j'avais personnes en plein hiver il
faisait froid
pas de lumière de bougies tu rigoles là
pas sûr que j'ai pleuré 1
oui j'ai pleuré tout seul j'avais peur
alors les bougies je suis monté au
premier étage dans des placards ah oui
des uniformes d'allemands suspendu mi
rien à manger trouver des lentilles et
moi je m'étais dit je vais rire de
résistance mais je ne veux pas prendre
de risques inutiles parce que j'avais
travaillé j'avais été prendre faire un
rapport avec un certain durandal je
pense qu'il est devenu s'est jamais revu
je crois que c'était un officier de
l'actif et maveety or savez a serial
mourir quand on est sur un travail s'est
vite fait et dit le pire et puissant des
dos nus quand même un peu réfléchi c'est
le pire c'est de les torturer par matt a
compris le truc il faut l'accepter puis
voilà je ferai donc attention en jeu on
faisait beaucoup d'écrits sur le futur
sur ce qui allait se passer parce qu'on
espérait bien que tout changerait que
l'esprit de la résistance resterait pas
qu'il n'a pas été tellement suivi mais
enfin bon
je suis là chez moi qui sais c'est pour
reconnaître cette mon premier rendez
vous rue boissac egée où je devais tenir
un journal à la main et on va me
demander que leur est il devait répondre
trente six heures parce que c'est rigolo
c'est comme dans les romans policiers
absolument et bien mais on m'a dit je ne
peux pas cette fois tout de suite on a
donné un autre rendez-vous place puvis
de chavannes l'église la rétention à
lyon
et là je me suis retrouvé avec deux
autres nous étions 3 1 gestion 3 pendant
qu'on faisait de faux papiers 20p pitch
c'est long des deux camarades qui
étaient avec moi
la spirit lan c'est l'endroit où nous
étions nous attendions nos papiers de
faux papiers
la révolution de techniques la
mondialisation et cetera qui étaient des
thèmes chers à robert je veux dire que
c'était un homme éminemment
impressionnant du moins pour moi ce que
j'aurais tenu d'un grand souriant je
dirais solaire c'était un soleil il
était flamboyant cet homme flamboyant
sympathique bien sûr enthousiastes bien
évidemment décidé à faire à faire des
choses et c'est là qu'il nous a parlé de
l'école des cadres pour la première fois
sa grande idée c'était de la révolution
de la technique
si la science accrue avec nos
connaissances la forme investigatrice de
notre pensée est là aussi par la
technique multiplié notre pouvoir sur
les choses et sur les hommes alors que
tout s'effondre la machine poursuit son
essor
seule la création peut vaincre le temps
nous ne pourrons donc vaincre le temps
dans notre vie qu'en faisant une
création continue et une création
parfaite
et puis on devait en partie
dans des maquis pour
les former pour les diriger et puis
finalement le parti dans les maquis et
bien finalement au moins deux
d'octobre 43 il a été décidé qu'on
rentrait tout comme montré pourtant dur
on est arrivé dans le jura et le
lendemain matin on est partis dans leur
camion de joe deux géants grosfilley qui
montait du ravitaillement
donc on a démonté un camion on atteint
là c'est saint claude
mais sous une branche pas ce qu'il
fallait pour qu'on ouvre et quand on a
été dans la montagne et le camion s'est
arrêté nous a débranché alors là ça
allait mieux et on était arrivé avant
gauche
donc j'étais en à dire hors plan groupe
là oui nous arrivons du wrp la dure plat
turp là nous arrivons dur plat nous nous
arrêtons là quand même chanter et c'est
qu'au mois de septembre au début
septembre que cet organisme
or plat de service périclès et que là
sont venus à peu pâle et les coffres du
maquis durant l'étape du maquis du haut
jura qui ont été un peu tous les anciens
avec tony avec eric bien d or et c'est
là
or plat lamoura que c'est organiser le
début
c'est comme la il venait de savoureux 10
10 heures de lisa ils me disaient ses
barbie qui étaient là ils en arrivaient
tout le temps à toutes les heures et
arrivée des types avec un sac une valise
il avait regroupé
je pense d des espèces des codes ou des
espèces de maquis un peu dans toute la
france parce qu'il en avait à laval à la
vendrai du tout comme ça ils sont tous
regroupés là
automne cette avancée on a vu les
paysans maître des piquets comme des
piquets pour ramer les haricots entre
les poteaux électriques dans les prés
signifie font ça correspond à quoi elle
en détail on demandé elle nous a dit
c'est pour pas se perdre
alors on s'est dit si les gens du cru ce
père divers qu'est ce qu'on va faire
nous dans le bruit à un bon niveau ça va
on a compris et en fait on s'est habitué
au climat situation et on sait c'est
pratiquement j'avais perdu en oeuvre et
puis robert trouvait que comment
dirais-je les gens tous ces maquisards
qui étaient là ils disent était trop
individualiste si vous voulez en gros et
c'est là où il leur avait dit il faut
quand même rendre service à tout le
monde c'est pas parce que l'un de
ceux-ci l'autre et cela que et c est
entre autres on a besoin de se chauffer
l'hiver arrive il faut faire des
provisions dans toutes les fermes par
philippe à ça je me souviens il parlait
d'un peu toutes les fermes on pouvait
trouver refuge par exemple ou se rendre
et alors il faut faire des provisions de
bois partout et il faut pas se contenter
de ramener chez pac wade branding est
comme ça il y avait je me souviens
j'avais assisté à cela il y avait été
sérieux hein c'était pas de la
plaisanterie ce qu'ils racontaient me
souviens de la phrase finale
oui il faut porter à bout de bras un
tour vous ne vous occupez de rien mais
si jamais je bats subra vous écraser
comme des merdes
parce que là il y avait été
jamais autant rigolé y avait un coup de
main ou que je participais pas sur des
chantiers de jeunesse et web a été
récupéré des vêtements des blousons des
pantalons et puis deux
la nourriture est notamment des bateaux
en chocolat
c'est vrai alors j'ai pas participer aux
coûts de man j'ai participé à une équipe
qui a été chargé d'aller chercher le
matériel était entreposé chez paou et de
ramener alors là une longue marche sous
la pluie de nuit avec je me rappelle mes
poches bourrées de ce bar de chocolat et
de chips on devait tous a fondé et
c'était une longue marche qui devait
faire je suis pas quarantaine de
kilomètres je me rappelle comme ça
énormément de marche de nuit et des
problèmes en particulier un problème par
idiots les problèmes des fils de fer
barbelés il fallait franchir est conviée
pour toujours la nuit web mais je n'ai
pas du tout un mauvais souvenir de ces
marches - quelque chose parfois pénible
non pas du tout un mauvais souvenir ces
marchés pour moi le souvenir du maquis
évier souvenir de la marche à pied dans
des forêts magnifique forêt vous dire
quand même c'est draine beaucoup avec
quelquefois clair de lune pour tous
aujourd'hui mais il faudrait de la
phrase la forêt des autres
passer d'une combe à une autre je me
rappelle de ma difficulté à identifier
les combes 60 tout en reconnaissant une
croix ou non à oui on s'y perd un super
mouvement appelle d'une nuit ou où je
voulais à l'aide des tuileries europe là
on s'est perdu dans les combes et il est
arrivé chez des paysans qui nous ont
combien voulu nous faire coucher dans le
foie on était très heureux de pouvoir
coucher les enfants parce que on était
complètement perdue pour mais alors
j'ajouterai à propos des marches qui
avait ces marches qui était pénible mais
il y avait autre chose qui étaient venus
étaient des gardes de nuit avec le froid
épouvantable on ce jeu l'est vraiment
non seulement ce que vous pouvez penser
et les pieds surtout les pieds
on avait des pieds jaunes et quand on
faisait deux trois heures de garde la
nuit avant d'être remplacé ont gardé
leur pour savoir quand est-ce qu'on
serait relayée oui je me rappelle est a
u avoir monté la garde de nuit oui soit
comme ça dans une espèce d'esprit
guerrier et j'avais pas d'art oui
j'avais je crois je crois que j'avais
entre les soufflets si oui il ya eu
alors une espèce de corne
je n'ai pas eu le flair de 10 ans dans
le fond il y avait trois grands
problèmes dans le maquis et voitures
avis times en est un très gros problème
quand même qu'au niveau de vie de notre
âge on est mené dans l'examen il y avait
le problème d'insécurité jeu et puis
elle pour un désert
[Musique]
mais
j'essayais en contact avec les chefs
m'écarte je suis négatif je rêve janin
peut en tirer
alors je leur ai dit quand est-ce que
robert va arriver j'ai attendu un parce
qu'on n'est pas ce grand robert et j'ai
fini par le rencontrer mais je pense que
j'ai dû le rencontrer
peu de temps après la l'inspection
l'inspection de de xavier et quand signé
que le troisième il avait un troisième
et je me souviens que le l'arrivée du
colonel anglais nous avait impressionné
on se dit cette fois on rentre dans la
résistance en dans l'armée on va se
battre
ouais c'était un peu d'illusions et
d'âgés axim j'ai assisté à la chorale
exposé de robert sur la lumière sur ce
qu'il voulait faire il a exposé sa à
l'engrais a continué alors il a exposé
fallait se bat il fallait se préparer
c'était le moment et tout ça et puis il
fallait voir plus loin il faisait noir
l'avenir et il a commencé la digue on va
vous faire un petit descriptif du monde
actuel la legends est un peu tôt mais
enfin il a commencé par voir les du
national-socialisme catastrophe
narcisse communiste catastrophe et en vo
saxons capitalisme catastrophe il a
parlé pendant à peu près 20 minutes moi
je sais que vous sortez un peu intérêt
parce que l'anglais écouter alors
demandé des armes à l'anglais en me
disant fond du fuchsia capitalisme
anglo-saxon
[Musique]
un peu
et je suis bien être et le bonheur et de
liberté débat est public
mais bon
[Applaudissements]
des belles copies en normandie installé
en normandie palais pour que ce sport
est une ville où vous apprendrez la
maman de dépôt des sens
et alors après j'ai vu j'ai vu robert il
m'a demandé ce que je faisais c'était
sympathique
je lui ai exposé mon affaire je dis je
suis pas commander un détachement
il m'a dit tout de suite il m'a dit tu
trouves un chalet tête installe deux ans
si tu connais des gens fait les venir je
t'enverrai du monde et cherche de la fac
gars du coin et c'est ce qu'on a fait et
c'est exactement ce que voulait faire
robert c'était s'étaient tous et des
gens qui ramassent un peu de tout le
monde pour les commander pour faire des
espèces de groupes de 20 30 puis on a
commencé de vivre de vivonne dans le
jura 7 l'entousiasme on allait y aller
pour les chasseurs
pour noël je leur avais apporté un
cadeau à tous une petite croix de
lorraine mais pas plus grosses que ça
que j'avais eue jésus mercière à vienne
dans l'isère qui connaît ce jeune ce
qu'il veut
croix de lorraine mais il y avait des
résistants partout une visite
extrêmement sympathique tous ces garçons
chantent la marseillaise sur tout et
puis après des chansons garde de toutes
sortes et puis y avait des gâteaux qui
avait été donnée par les habitants des
alentours elle même le l'instituteur du
coin avait fait faire des démos gentil
vos enfants des petits jouets des choses
comme ça leur avait expliqué et puis
c'était très poignant parce que ce bs ce
noël au milieu de la neige dans cette
atmosphère ce garçon qui tu es c'est
vraiment extraordinaire
comment il s'appelle sarrazac il voulait
chasser les allemands dans la bombe et
la prière c'est un bon exemple de
mentalité des gens qui étaient dans
l'organisation était très catholique
moi j'étais enthousiaste pourquoi pour
pouvoir le chat sait jamais et les gens
les gens s'agglutinent eh bien j sujet
j'ai eu un peu de difficulté qu'un
facteur parce que c'est l'équipe c'est y
vivent et ils vivaient peinardement pour
rester des vacances on leur apporter à
manger il allait au bal du samedi soir
un jour car il n'est pas tellement là ni
l'armée ni les maquisards et eux j'ai su
après et ils avaient envisagé pour quand
ils sont dit tiens on est tombé sur un
militaire ne m'emmerdez on va mais ils
sont paris sont restés non non non
celui-ci n'est pas fait on a eu peur un
groupement rigoler et cuire le corps qui
vous dira connais un qui n'a pas eu peur
et c'est un menteur un menteur
on fait peut-être bien saouler la gueule
aurait été bien que c'est d'avoir un bon
terreau pour le temps mon désert
[Musique]
c'était moins sévère c'était plutôt des
gens d'expérience qui s'était peu frotté
l'armée allemande quelquefois qui disait
ben voilà comment il faut faire et la
plupart du temps la meilleure chose de
conserver sa vie c'était la fuite
il est piloté par b j'ai tiré la groupie
publiés il a sauté dans les orties
heures on est farceur matoub après votre
pognon
c'était des moments qui restent encore
vous allez voir le but c'était donc de
nous former puis dehors de nous envoyer
ensuite en équipe volante deux par deux
c'est comme l'est comme les gendarmes
fait sortir par de deux par deux dans
des régions où en or m encadré donc des
jeunes qui étaient réfractaires au sto
pour former des maquis et puis donner un
certain esprit on a eu des équipes
formidables comme carrier joyeuse d'aidé
type formidable mais le nombre de types
qui ont été arrêtés
déporté ou fusillés a été certainement
203 même peut-être même les trois quarts
parce que et puis alors il est certain
que que dans les pyrénées atlantique en
bretagne ou en normandie ou dans meneur
on ne nous attendait pas les équipes
étaient formées les chefs c'était
s'était imposé 6h45 levée des tanks
matinale emploi du temps première
période session du 17 au 22 août
15h15 épluchage légumes lecture
collective 16h30 travaux de propreté et
de théorique lecture collective action
civique 11 à 12 heures nettoyage
instruction soutenir l'éducation
physique épluchage l'aigu 14h10 moi
d'avoir 19h30 travaux toilettes sont
pleines et 2010 anthony du soir
performances individuelles que les
couches et minutes des sessions de
formation des sessions de 15 jours
prochains buzz mais ça a été assez
efficace et là j'ai eu un renseignement
quand vous essayez de faire une espèce
d'historique de ça il ya brunel qui est
un qui est un ancien du gang cyrus qui
venaient me voir on ne sait toujours
ensemble et il m'avait raconté quand il
avait fini sa formation
on l'avait envoyé dans un camp et il a
trouvé il est arrivé alors gonflé il m'a
dit mme auger jean goubert et taillé
dans un camp qui est en hibernation
gtp l'âge du poids qui citait en
pagaille mais il s'était été pena et lui
lui ça m'avait français c'est que ça
prouvait qu'il avait tout de même reçu
une formation il avait cette formation
était petit et efficace parce que il en
voulait il est tombé dans le top qui
était pas il y reste est jugé bien
l'intégrer dans fin c'est la réaction de
brunel sous le camp ce point
d'importance mais c'est la réception de
brunel qui dit j'ai été déçu je croyais
qu'il y avait de l'animation
ce qui prouve qu'il a bien conclu j'ai
donné aussi dans un sens inverse des
gens qui a fait une session et qui n'en
avaient pas du tout est content parce
qu'il n'était pas politiquement si je
puis dire du même avis que que robert et
qui ont quitté le maquis à cause de
saint aimé je peux pas dire exactement
pourquoi prix les le groove et utopie
caetera et avec ses citoyens du monde et
c'est l'école de cadres
dérobert c'était un peu lu riaj du
maquis jean marie domenach était très
engagé à uriage et il était très très
copains et dans la résistance à la
faculté il était avec le serbe qui lui
était dans notre école de cadres
il avait certainement des des points
communs et alors là on a vécu la danse
en sont tout problème on oppose y
allèrent jusqu'au bout jusque vers le
père 15 décembre où on nous a dit fausse
trotter il va y avoir une attaque de
désalement lors du parti vert de
chrétiens là on était un mâle a trait et
on a recommencé de s'installer de vivre
là
et après ça a été une déshérence comme
ça on a changé le shérif assez souvent
le 18 décembre 43 après manon le maquis
margaine proche de périclès est attaquée
par l'armée allemande
c'est le lendemain même du jour je suis
arrivé on m'a dit tu médecin ses choix
de films à 10h tu es médecin vient de
voir il ya peut-être encore des
survivants
et moi je savais pas du tout je me suis
trouvé tout à coup il y avait de la
neige à blanc en abondance il ya comme
parfois il y en a dans le même temps le
dans le mac dans le haut jura
il y avait une il a au moins une
quinzaine de types que j'ai vu qu'il
était mort qu il était congé un déjà il
avait passé toute la nuit peut-être
davantage ne sait trop rien il y avait
au moins quinze type il y avait déjà eu
quelques villageois du coin qui était en
train de les extirper de la neige
et c'est là où j'ai vu qu'ils étaient
vraiment con julien alors il n'y avait
rien à faire moi je pouvais rien faire
de toute façon je veux dire quand je
suis arrivé au maquis moi j'avais rien
j'arrive même pas je veux dire prendre
cette scop
robert je vous dis tout de suite il m'a
dit ah ben toi j'avais en gros d'une
façon tout à fait général en gros 10 ans
plus que les autres que les jeunes qu'il
avait avec lui alors il m'a dit ah ben
tu aurais dû le second c'est pas
compliqué maintenant que comme dans le
second du groupe
s'il connaît rien moi en gros vous venez
d'arriver à me dire ça fait rien tu
étais là péter médecins ils ont
confiance en toi avant robert nous le
disait nu 10h un symbole de chef mais il
ne disait pas tous marre ils étaient ils
avaient toujours besoin d'argent et je
l'avais dit bon ben vas voir mon père
sûrement il arrangera quelque chose
alors ils étaient à mon père sa fabrique
de soirée et il a vu mon père et mon
beau-frère et après il m'en parlait il a
obtenu ce qu'il voulait et après ils
demandent mon père et mon beau-frère
maintenant par le monde y met ce type là
il peut ou veut faire n'importe quoi il
a une aura c'est extraordinaire moi je
sais que j'avais emmené en tant
qu'étudiant ce que j'avais emmené un
livre un seul un gros livre d'un
psychologue seidel pradines et que j'ai
toujours j'ai pas comment il est encore
devant la formidable de même que carte
raconte enfin pu tout c'est sa femme qui
raconte puisqu'il est né mon que michel
henry n'a justement quand quand il est
parti à sousse à qui l'avait emmené
qu'un seul bouquin 2 2 boucles an plus
tôt un bouquin de cartes justement la
critique de la raison pure et un autre
bouquin sur cape qui était le bouquin de
mon père fait par mon père il dit à
l'isq anciens
olli a été tuée gars devant moi j'étais
un mètre de lui oui du coup une rafale
on croyait qu'elle ait pas tellement on
était bien tranquille son plateau tout
d'un coup il ya eu deux enfants elle
tire une rafale et j'ai vu une poly to b
devant moi et on était à la file
indienne
j'étais juste derrière lui alors comment
s'est dispersée bien entendu comme sont
attendus la rue fans
moi je me suis retrouvé personnellement
dans un espèce de trou j'avais il ya des
armes et où j'étais à l'abri parce que
c'était un peu creux le problème c'était
d'en sortir
j'ai pris mon courage à deux mains ou à
trois oui j'ai fait un bon et j'ai
retrouvé les camarades qui la plupart
s'étaient réfugiés sur le versant du sol
au sein du plateau
chevassus il m'avait dire ben oui mais
tu verras quand tu seras aux moussières
là tu vas tomber sur l'éco gîte heures
je vous jure c'est ce qui m'a déjà
pratiquement mot pourront alors je dis
tiens l'écogîte rbc telle qu'est ce que
c'est alors il n'a rien expliqué un peu
ce qu il me dit bah c'est en gros il m'a
dit nous au lieu de s'occuper de nous
faire manger ce soir par exemple nous
nous ils sont dans les grandes théories
le monde et cetera bon moi j'étais sans
rappeler les kogis terre qui faisait les
conférences qui discutaient des
discussions hautement philosophique et
puis il y avait et si rare les yeux il y
avait quelques cadres les deux j'avais
les types comme nous étions entre les
deux séries d'aider des étudiants
quittent est en préparation un conte
normale supérieure ces derniers temps en
khâgne je veux plusieurs can you were
here on à 20 ans j'étais wistel écogîte
heures il met les conférenciers
conférence est d'abord il y avait robert
qu'il y avait robert key
la bonne parole il ya des volontaires il
y avait il eu lieu il ya eu aussi d un
fichier de carrière de la coloniale eux
ils nous apprenait les chansons je me
suis bien plus son gant il y en avait un
qui était marrant oui
l'information était encore c'était bien
c'était bien périclès nous on aurait
aimé être armé rapidement et puis entrer
en guerre en faire quelque chose
du reste qu'on s'est aperçu après que
avec larmes en plomb à 20 mis à part les
sabotages
on était inexistant et c'était pas
l'avis de robert l'avait robert nuit y
pensait après et il nous a souvent dit
mais des problèmes que vous avez
maintenant ce n'est rien à côté des
problèmes qu'il y aura après la défaite
de l'allemagne
et c'est là où dans le fond et
rejoignait uriage dillies vous le fonds
était gens capables de
de prendre le pays en main après c'est
le jour où les allemands seront parties
que nous pourrons penser à la libération
un pays n'est pas libre quand il ne peut
pas être occupés il est libre quand il
ne peut plus être occupés autrement dit
la liberté n'existe pas sans force
intérieure et un pays n'a plus de force
intérieure quand il a perdu le sens de
sa mission
[Musique]
créer un monde nouveau il fallait
changer les mentalités
c'est pas été très généreuse si vous
voulez dans sa pensée
d'ailleurs après après s'est lancé dans
cette histoire de citoyenneté du monde
citoyen du monde
c'était une instruction civique très
généreuse comme nouveau chef rédigé en
ratatine tous les titres afflux ont
bousillé toutes mettra plein les
collabos tout ça on épargne ceux qui
n'ont rien fait métiers de coeur avec
vous et puis on fait des choses
moralement bien voilà ce que je pense et
moi
moralement bien faut pas être méchant
faut faut pas être voleur il faut bien
répartir le travail donner du travail à
tout le monde
d'égalité avec les femmes n'en parlait
pas de ça l'entrée de rajouter moi c'est
ça que j'avais dans la tête
voix c'était ça ou rien et tout ça ça
date d'après guerre dan et sympathisants
une faune humains étaient justificatifs
il faut aux mains ce serait non
connaître les dangers les ennemis
communs
la totalité des sommes la paix ne peut
pas être sensible des relations exactes
au nouveau au niveau réel de la vie
militaire mondiale conditions de
l'établissement d'une paix mondiale par
les citoyens du monde alors là il ya
huit âge non ce ne l'est pas
[Applaudissements]
il y avait une notice directive il parti
unitaire d'occident nous avons propager
la foi unités une volonté
révolutionnaire à découvrir est assez
fumeux c'était assez fumeux non comme
projet après la guerre donc il fallait
ce n'est chose que que ne tombe pas bien
capable de réaliser
on avait entre 20 et 24 ans et 23 ans
cédant que on ne sait pas bien la vie
j'en ai un peu comment ça où il y avait
le bc oui avait pas que des sévillanes
et le centre d'accueil nombreux faisait
en nommant il a il y avait la tendance
sur quoi je vais plus voir se faire un
mystérieux la halle où le peut-être
montre une seule dans la halle de bien
wilhelm à photographier en es-tu en
allemand mais luis tremblay prendre la
photo ça fait je suis pas net
mais lui moi j'ai pris nettement et de
l'amour
c'était gris mois de septembre
c'est comme cette année quoi puis ça
s'est gâté et puis est arrivée la neige
je pense la neige tombée fin octobre
puis on est tombé c'était hélas c'est ça
c'est du jeu arrêté toute vie on est
parce que quand vous êtes dans la neige
et le froid
l'éco gîte heures je vais pas tout ce
qu'il faisait dans les conférences et
tout ça c'est du alors quand ils sont
partis je sais pas les chefs cartes et
tous ces gens là quand ils sont pas ils
sont repliés à lyon
la vision idéale d'un monde fraternel
etc
il essayait d'imposer au moment où on
pouvait pas aucune idée des conditions
pour arriver à ça autrement dit aucune
idée sur la structure institutionnelle
politique économique idéologique avec
les journaux tout ça il n'a pas vu ça
l'a vu mieux la crue qui pour elle a
dominé avec ses cadres à l'école
c'est ça son sa naïveté face à ça je
suis sûr que ça c'est un type honnête
aubert
durandal au chef de chalais depuis mon
arrivée au camp du jura plus
particulièrement depuis la visite des
chefs départementaux et régionaux maquis
et le départ de robert beaucoup de mes
anciens élèves ou des nouveaux arrivants
viennent me trouver individuellement et
mme expriment leur inquiétude devant la
parente inaction de cette période
d'attentes leur désarroi même de
constater que le mât qui ne répond pas à
ce qu'ils espéraient
les difficultés de la clandestinité
trop de responsabilités au niveau
national des illusions sur ce rêve de
changer le monde par la jeunesse
personne ne sait mais à partir de
décembre 43
robert ne fait plus d'apparitions dans
le haut jura
l'école de cadres se constitue alors en
différents camps martin pauli cyrus
intégrant progressivement les maquisards
du printemps et de l'été 44
et ces matinées au jura qui étaient nés
dans des compositions comme champignons
et de décomposition de périphérie c'est
le maquis a vraiment démarré après le
parachutage de viry du groupe renault
il ya eu les parrainent le parachute en
guise et où tous les cas ont été
remerciés russe polyphonie et c'est là
que le ils sont venus une partie qui
sont venus à la versanne à l'arrivée
était avant l attaque elle a eu lieu le
sait paris le 7 avril la verdad alors la
versanne depuis quelques temps il y
avait des bruits de que les allemands
les veut dire non mais alors il ya une
période où on prenait position de combat
tous les matins à l'aube et puis bon
vous y'a rien arriver jusqu'au moment où
musulmans sont arrivés et le convoi
s'est arrêté devant nous
avec mme émond étaient les premiers sur
rhône à nous notre position avec le fn
les autres se sont éparpillés plus ou
moins c'est là qu'on a commencé à tirer
mais les allemands avaient l'habitude de
se battre se battaient très bien et ils
sont aussitôt lancé une bombe fumigène
une ou plusieurs bombes fumigènes si
bien qu' on a pas on après on s'est
retirée peu cieux on voyait plus rien
alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait là bas
et ils se sont éparpillés dans la nature
derrière il y avait des tas de fumier il
faut se sont planqués et nous ont
canardé il y avait des tirs de
mitrailleuses qui nous pensaient au
dessus dessus de la tête et ça claque
d'ailleurs ça siffle pas ça claque quand
ça si ce n'est pas dangereux c'est quand
ça claque que ça passe pas loin ça
s'écrasait sur la falaise derrière nous
et puis au bout d'un an
alors c'est d'un aussi que j'ai bombe à
la journée qu en pense et on a commencé
à avoir faim et je suis remonté au camp
pour chercher à manger aux copains
arabes issus les sens avec du pg trouver
du pain et j'ai trouvé des oignons et
manquent pas je ne savais pour devenir
mon copain ravissent horreur des oignons
ville à 10 et où si tu trouve autre
chose qu'ils veulent chercher moi je
mange et on alors il a mangé le pas moi
je mangeais le pas et puis les oignons
et si on était redescendu dans ce trou
et c'est d'erreurs qu'on avait fait
seulement avait repéré ce trou ils ont
retiré dedans et nous mais on a été
blessé le soir sur les coups de 3 heures
je pense oui oui ben le matin il y avait
déjà eu des tués finn ou alors après
c'était l'ordre de dispersion c'était un
peu le bazar alors moi je suis parti de
l'autre côté tu parti tout seul pour
finir et j'ai descendu la versanne de
l'autre côté vers la mer la rivière
je suis arrivé à ronnie a alors je suis
pas rentré dans la première maison chez
pourquoi se rencontrer dans la deuxième
et puissante eu peu de moi et puis il ya
d'autres gars du maquis qui sont arrivés
et aramis lui est descendu aussi mais il
n'a pas passé la rivière le pont le soir
il n'a passé que lendemain le lendemain
matin donc surveiller et puis sur le
chat j'ai dit bhv
je vais aller à revenir à l'hôpital
jusqu'au suspect t il pas d'être un
hôpital on y invite l avenir alors je
suis parti et je suis arrivé à rognan
bref un précieux puis il ya une dame à
une fenêtre qui m'a vu arriver elle m'a
dit vous avez pas judicieux l'hôpital
hekma type autre hôpital
[Musique]
dans la première demie alors ça va aller
[__] la paix la poursuite de
camaraderie assez extraordinaire j'ai
pratiquement jamais eu de dispute
j'ai jamais je garde le souvenir
d'aucune dispute d'importance
[Musique]
elle a compté
les esprits périclès c'est à dire penser
à ce qui se passera après
[Musique]